so what was it that made you think of
Denzel when you sat down to write the
script the character that he's playing
is somebody really deeply believes in
something and Denzel in his real life
actually really believes in something I
just had never read anything like this
before
I hadn't been asked to play a character
like this before I may not have been
ready to play a character like this till
now but I've never liked the character
that I played as much as this one I sit
down at the beginning and I say I want I
want to be your creative partner I am
open to your ideas I want to explore
things with you
I really want the best of you I'm not
here to tell you what to do if you have
a question you can ask me but I want to
create a space that you feel comfortable
creating it the blueprint the bet that
Dan laid out my brilliant blueprint and
then I started asking questions but why
is he alone why doesn't he have a
girlfriend and I did it led me to the
spectrum and Asperger's and I said I
think why is his social skills the way
they are why is he a bit clumsy why you
know and I and I try to answer those
questions and you start to build the
character what is it like when you
opposite him in a scene you know I had
to really keep up with the things that
he was playing around with there's so
many sort of colors and nuances that
he's been to Roman Israel a lot of fun
as a filmmaker do you feel a
responsibility to tell this these kind
of stories in your culture and and get
people out there thinking about things
in a new way if you have the opportunity
to do it now I'm of the mindset that if
I'm gonna make a film I want to be
commercial I wanted to be entertaining
but I wanted people to think we should
care I mean helping someone who's laid
out on the ground doesn't make you an
activist makes you a human being you
know we ought to be active in our
kindness